yeah so Shawn Mendes and Camila Kibeho
are Directioners let's rewind on Sunday
Shawn and Camila hit up the Universal
Records Grammy after-party where they
lived their best freaking lives crazy
the lovebirds jumped up on a table in
saying one Direction's 2014 hit steal my
girl at the top of their lungs I'm gonna
have to say you know what I feel very me
tonight okay so honestly it was less
like singing and more like screaming but
I'm here for it and as if that video
wasn't enough to get you all up in your
feelings look a little closer and you'll
see Niall Horan yeah Niall like One
Direction heartthrob Niall right there
on hand to sing backup for his own song
also singing along Grammy nominee Lewis
Capaldi oh and fun sidebar Tana mojo is
the one who caught all this Sean Camilla
One Direction dancing on the table fun
on camera posting it to her insta story
so thanks Tana anyway back to Sean Mila
the couple sparked a brief moment of
concern at the Grammys on Sunday after
they opted to walk the red carpet
separately
the two have been together for over six
months now walking tons of red carpets
together living that PDA life to the
fullest
we just finally really kiss yeah
you so naturally fans were fifty Shades
of worried but don't worry guys
Camila pulled a cute AF move bringing
her dad as her plus one oh and can we
talk about how she dedicated her
performance of first man at the Grammys
to her dad and he teared up before they
open up the doors I said I've never seen
you cry before they never look so
beautiful I can't it's too cute Sean and
Camila were nominated for Best Pop
duo/group Performance for seniorita and
the Havana singer promised they would
walk the stage in their underwear to
accept the award if they won if Sean and
I win the Grammy
we will walk onstage in our underwear
like twenty one pilots did that's a
promise just kidding it's not it's not I
got it I got to work out before I do
that but her dad was her date awkward so
awkward I guess lucky for them they
didn't have to make good on that promise
since lil nas ex and Billy Ray Cyrus
scooped up the award for Old Town Road
but these little lovebirds they're still
winning I've always loved him when eg
caught up with Camilla in December she
opened up about her love for Sean I've
said that a lot I mean as I do obviously
like I love him in he's my boyfriend way
but I've always loved him as just I just
love him
I mean cuties of course you can count on
et to keep you in the know on all things
Sean Mila so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
you